(ambient music)
- [President Duterte] In my country,
there's three million drug addicts.
I'd be happy to slaughter
them to finish the problem.
(tense music)
- [Female News Anchor] Officers
have repeatedly been accused
of hunting down and executing people,
(gun clicks and bangs)
but they insist all the killings
are the result of shootouts.
(man speaking in Tagalog)
(gun clicks and bangs)
(camera shutter clicks)
(siren wails)
- The Nightcrawlers is a group
of photojournalists
trying to tell this story.
It's a collective effort.
(gun clicks and bangs)
(camera shutter clicks)
- [Male News Anchor]
They hurry to the scene
to get a shot of the body
before the authorities
can clean up the site.
(gun clicks and bangs)
(camera shutter clicks)
(man speaking in Tagalog)
(woman wailing)
- She just found out her husband was dead.
- It's so heartbreaking, man.
(man speaking in Tagalog)
(gun clicks and bangs)
- Every day, you cover these scenes.
You begin to fear for your life.
(gun clicks and bangs)
We will be vigilant.
We will be watching them.
(gun clicks and bangs)
(camera shutter clicks)
(gun bangs)
We have to actively
challenge what's happening,
because we know it's wrong.
We know it's wrong.
(ominous ambient music)